[Musique]
et il ya eu un terrible accident
tu as eu la chance d'être à sortir
non d'abord parce qu'on s'est dit
je crois parce qu'une fille pardon
j'avais jamais vu de film en garde ses
bas car nous aussi on appelle ça le
bruit tous les hommes de cette planète
l'entendent
toutes les pensées qu'on a en tête sont
visibles ou sont tout les sens
elles sont mortes pas de quoi bon sens
et son bruit ça fait bizarre de voir tes
plantes et et c'est bizarre pour moins
de pas voir ce que tu as en tête
j'ignore si tu déteste mon chien ou si
tu as envie de me frapper avec une
pierre dans l'envié de tourner ton chien
je la gare il est plus fort qu'une de
l'apport 7e attention avec tombola repas
serpent
si la trappe
il te tuerons
qui veut protéger quatre filles il faut
que vous partiez
je vais te protège te protéger frotter
avec le pouvoir que l' on ne sait pas de
quoi il est capable
ils ne font cette fille
combien vous débarquez 102 ans des
milliers
[Musique]
allez je suis de derrick soir nomme
j'essaie je te suis pas toi bats toi
[Musique]